upgrade a little bit not even a lot I'm
not even asking for Nintendo to operate
a lot but to me like okay they had keep
the hybrid you know but I do think
that they would do a lot better if they
tried to bring in a little bit more
third party you know what I'm saying
like so what I would like and you know
is to have like a dock that can make it
the the actual switch stronger that you
could play those third parties at home
like you could play all the other stuff
on the go but just the third party stuff
that they can't that they just simply
don't have enough power to play
um I I think they need to bring their
games into the 21st the 22nd century
and actually have voice
overs I think it's ridiculous that I'm
playing games that I'm still reading all
this dialogue years apart from each
other when